when i build serverless systems i like
to use a serverless nosql database like
firestore or datastore i don't have to
worry about maintenance and they scale
up really well
they do that because they're optimized
for accessing only a few records at a
time and that's fine for most web and
mobile apps but to run a business you
also need analytics and to do analytics
you need to read thousands or millions
of records at a time that's often too
slow in nosql databases so how do we get
the analytics that we need to run our
business
here's how i do it
i run a nightly job that imports my
nosql database into bigquery which is
also serverless by the way
bigquery is optimized for analytics and
can easily run queries across millions
of records also with separate databases
the app can't slow down the analytics
and vice versa
now that the data is in bigquery it's
easy to create a dashboard in data
studio to drive business decisions
how do you handle analytics for your app
let me know in the comments